yeah I mean some of these are so easy
like go to the first one I know okay
would you rather live in the world of
the MCU or Invincible okay that's this
is an easy one right wait it is is it it
is why would you want to live in the
world of invincible wait I was going to
say invincible why because it's
sick what do you wait bro you you are
you are literally like a [__] ant in
the Invincible world oh like I'm half
the [__] population died in the MCU
well cuz [__] cuz a [__] Mr purple
[__] head but they also did an
invincible as well yeah but nobody
suffers pain in the MCU right guys you
know yeah I they're like Pokemon they
just faint look look look you know I
would rather just fade from existence
rather than getting like my skull
crushed or
[__] like imagine you're just on the
[__] train and like the Invincible
characters just start start a [__]
fight there you're going to die this is
this is a [__] one because it's like in
reality you're just going to be like a
civilian in both these universes right
it's not going to make F it's not going
to make a difference you're going to
probably get caught up we're going to
get caught up in some like [__]
between like superheroes and either way
you're you're you're
helpless okay all right but then you
know because we have that one which you
know started a debate but the next
person asks all right would you rather
get into a car crash or eat a burger so
you know we have some really really
intelligent uh questions being asked
here and I honestly you know this is a
this is a on society as a whole what do
we value more physical body or what the
ramifications are of I would be sweating
if I was a vegetarian question yeah if
you say eat a burger well that means you
support the meat industry and the meat
industry is very problematic so I just
want to it's either you get hurt or the
entire Humanity gets hurt cuz you're
eating burgers and you won't stop well
think think of it this way who do you
what do you think kills more people per
year hamburgers is it car crash or or or
is it everything that the burger in
heart disease
Burgers Let's Just Ask America for a
second yeah car crashes how do people
get into car crashes on the way to get a
burger oh [__] you're onr
my isn't it like cow burps like are the
biggest reason as to like or farts or BS
whichever one it was of why the ozone
layer is Getting Thinner or something no
no well okay okay F Paul M has to fact
check right
away it's something like that it it it's
not like it's a lot but it's not as much
as gas of particles and
[Music]
waves travel through a vacuum obviously
right we've we've made it how long in uh
trash taste just before this is got to
be a speedrun of I mean I wouldn't call
it a trash episode listen list it's bad
it's bad but the point is you would
definitely want to get into a no was
right methane can react with other gases
to form water vapor which then break
down into other chemicals that destroyed
I wasn't arguing that it didn't affect
the Oz but you were saying it like it's
the most leading cause of like pain to
the ozone destruction cows do definitely
play it's a big percentage I remember
that it's it's a bigger percentage what
you would imagine it to be the ozone
layer we're [__] chill with now it's
the [__] uh the other what's the
other [__] layer ah [__] the ozone
layer we we we we basically fixed the
ozone layer there was a hole in the
ozone layer and we stopped using the
chemical so we basically were chill with
that we we can [__] it up still so we
try not to be [__] it up but it's the uh
other [__] layer the one with all the
greenhouse gases that stuck point being
get in a [__] car crash no not
Stratosphere that's that's when you get
into space that's wait are you talking
about uh the greenhouse effect thater uh
yeah but yeah he literally just said
that but it's different the ozone layer
is separate I I know theone layer is
different from that but the greenhouse
effect is not a layer of should we
clearly
know talking about this I don't know how
we started we're not
qualified
something start throwing out facts we
can't see facts on trash I was saying
the correct fact and then you were like
what's the layer with the greenhouse no
no you did not say the correct fact M on
fact checked him oh my God all right
back to the pat yeah the answer is eat a
[__] Burger can't
crash I don't want to destroy the
environment Joey I don't want that my
conscience I will never see you eating
another Burger again from this stay
onwards you will never see it mark my
words you'll never see it it won't
happen uh just to spite uh I will just
eat a burger while driving
my oh I'm going to [__] around and find
out get in a car crash in your last
dying moment just I'mma [__] around find
out and see what happens when I eat a
burger while I'm driving a car devil
Advocates today yeah all right let's go
next one uh leave trash taste but you
get 10 million I assume dollars and
can't be friends with the boys again or
stay in trash taste and keep making what
you're making bro $10 million I'm sorry
boys but the [__] off what the [__] I S
trash taste the Fu [__] off boys we
still get paid we still hang out you
know I'm I'm going cry myself to my $10
million Villa thank you very much yeah
go how many G PS did I get you huh what
you you'll be back in a week guys the 10
mil all right
out I need more I'm back guys what the
[__] are you are you going to take me
back guys I don't know what would you do
10 mil right I take the 10 mil I make a
new
podcast I get I get another I get a I
get a not a tie that's too close I get a
Vietnamese friend and I get the 10 mil I
buy the rights to
trash I would sell you the rights trash
and then get a Scottish guy and a
Vietnamese guy to co-host with I I'll
get the 10 mil we we get a Bollywood
actor I'll get a Bollywood actor I'll
actually pay him to watch anime this
time yeah I love it if we're like so un
like we're not even friends and we have
to like we one of us is hanging them to
be friends like no no no joy wouldn't
say that didn't watch that
Anime Con would argue with me on this
you don't understand if I say this food
take you got to say [__] off God cut cut
redo this oh my God okay but yeah we we
take the teral I would I would I would I
think I'd stay no no realistically I'd
stay realistically these patrons they're
helping us get eventually we'll get
there definitely oh my Lord Revan Moore
asks would you rather have everyone you
know be able to read your thoughts or
everyone you know to have access to your
internet history this isn't easy are you
kidding me why the [__] would you want
anyone to be able to read your mind
constantly right yeah yeah that's are
you I would I would argue for a lot of
people that's worse give me 10 bucks
I'll give you my internet history I know
man if if you have nothing to hide then
uh what are you talking about what we
all have those intrusive thoughts I
don't have any intrusive thoughts I
don't know what you're talking about you
literally said you get in a car crash
eat a burger what are
talking like we're driving right that be
so funny actually you know you know like
well you're standing in line of MCD
you're like I'd rather be in a car crash
yeah we're driving a car right and I'm
driving and then you just think wonder
what Conor thinking and you like Conor's
like I can crash the car right it's like
the one intrusive thought I have you're
going to think what the [__] I don't
want people snooping in my brain my
brain does [__] up stuff I didn't give
permission to do that by the way brain
didn't I did not tell her to do that
honestly I think reading Minds is one of
the biggest monkey po kind of like
abilities you could ask for cuz that
would be that would mean you could never
have a friendship or any kind of social
connection ever in your life at all um
because no matter how innocent they look
on the outside everyone has [__] up
thoughts yeah you know yeah right you
can't avoid that right I I would like it
would be funny though if we could read
each other's mind and we just be
like would we get to the point where we
couldn't tell if we were thinking
something or if someone actually was
saying something yeah like like we'd be
in a conversation I just look at gun and
i' be like don't say what you're about
to say I'm like bro really really Joey
now now you're thinking that you'd
probably find a way to somehow suppress
your thoughts I feel like I can't do
that you can you do that you do it out
of desperation okay okay just keep
screaming I think I think I think the
idea
of I think the idea of suppressing your
thoughts is like something that makes
sense in your own head but in reality I
I don't think it's possible oh it is
possible it's called meditation uh I
said
medication well that that pretty helps
too that also helps yeah I mean it's
it's very very like it's you know as
someone who's done meditation before
it's way harder to suppress your
thoughts than uh you kind of like
mentally think it would be there is
techniques that help you to do that yeah
like try to consciously stop thinking
try it like try and stop thinking for
like a second well now that you said
that I it's so hard but like meditation
isn't exactly like stopping thinking
just being aware of what you're thinking
uh it's it's like like that whole idea
of if I said like don't think of a pink
elephant you're thinking of a pink
elephan right now like it's just it's
are you reading my
mind anyway yeah it's okay though we're
we're close enough friends that we can
already read each other's mind